[Música]
eeuu continúa en vilo dos días después
de las elecciones presidenciales
mientras sigue el conteo de votos en
cinco estados georgia carolina del norte
nevada pensilvania y alaska
donaldson renovó sus acusaciones de
fraude sin ningún tipo de prueba y
comenzó una batalla legal para un
reconteo de papeletas bailén acumula 264
votos electorales y está a 6 de los
necesarios para ganar mientras trump
suma 214
agitada noche de protestas la mayoría
pacíficas en los estados que siguen el
conteo de votos y otras ciudades que ya
finalizaron el escrutinio sin embargo se
registraron algunos disturbios en nueva
york' y en portland donde hubo decenas
de detenidos incluso saqueos
la tormenta eta continúa a su paso por
centroamérica el fenómeno natural
ingresó a honduras después de golpear
con fuerza las costas de nicaragua y
dejará al menos cuatro personas
fallecidas y numerosas inundaciones y
comunidades bajo el agua por la fuertes
lluvias también desbordamiento de ríos y
cortes de carretera
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 se redoblan con gusto
saludarlos comenzamos a este informativo
en eeuu donde el candidato demócrata joe
biden tiene la ventaja en estas
elecciones y va ganando en los estados
de michigan y wisconsin mientras que el
candidato presenta donald trump pide un
reconteo de los votos en los estados
donde los resultados no son favorables
para él veamos como está entonces el
mapa electoral hasta el momento en el
país job aiden acumula 264 votos
electorales y está a 6 de los necesarios
para ganar esta elección presidencial
mientras que donald trump acumula 214 y
la campaña de reelección del mandatario
republicano impugnó el conteo de votos
en wisconsin y michigan donde los medios
proyectaron el triunfo del candidato
demócrata además de pensilvania estado
en el que badén lleva a la desventaja
pero falta todavía el cómputo de zonas
tradicionalmente demócratas
es que varias ciudades estadounidenses
vivieron durante la jornada de ayer
multitudinarias protestas poselectorales
a favor y en contra de ambos candidatos
los simpatizantes de donald trump exigen
el recuento de todos los votos o también
realizar un conteo mientras que quienes
votan por bailén piden que se respete el
proceso democrático y que finaliza el
conteo de todas las papeletas enviadas
por correo aunque la mayoría de
protestas fueron pacíficas algunas se
transformaron en disturbios produciendo
decenas de arrestos como en la ciudad de
nueva york donde incluso hubo saqueos al
igual que en portland en el estado de
oregon
mientras tanto en filadelfia pensilvania
en detroit michigan y atlanta georgia
los manifestantes del lado y lado
estuvieron reunidos en torno a los
centros de conteo para apoyar a sus
candidatos andrés en mesa muñoz tiene
todos los detalles
cada voto cuenta
[Música]
esta consigna se extiende por todo eeuu
en medio de las protestas que exigen que
nada detenga el conteo de las papeletas
de las elecciones presidenciales
regresamos aquí porque donald trump hizo
un falso reclamo de victoria díganlo
conmigo un falso reclamo de victoria
a menos que la gente se ponga de pie y
dejen claro que cada voto tiene que ser
contado la elección será robada a medida
que yo by the end ganaba terreno el
presidente de donaldson denunciaba
fraudes sin ningún fundamento su campaña
emprendió acciones legales e instó a que
no se reciban más votos por correo en
pensilvania a recontar las papeletas de
wisconsin y a detener los conteos en
georgia y michigan su llamado hizo que
sus simpatizantes acudiera al centro de
conteo en la ciudad de dicho para exigir
que se detenga el escrutinio
[Aplausos]
vayan derrotó a trauma en michigan y
wisconsin por un estrecho margen la
campaña de trauma exige que sus
observadores estén presentes en el
escrutinio los ojos están ahora en
nevada donde el conteo continúa pero los
resultados empezarán a ser revelados
este jueves
en nueva york y washington también se
vivió algo similar los partidarios de
bailén dicen temer por la democracia y
los simpatizantes de donald trump ponen
en tela de juicio las papeletas enviadas
por correo
están en las calles de todo el país
pensilvania michigan illinois nueva york
frente a los repetidos llamados del
presidente de donald trump para detener
el conteo de votos estos activistas
demócratas quieren que sus voces sean
escuchadas y esperábamos este escenario
llevamos semanas preparando este
discurso porque sabíamos que la elección
iba a ser disputada así que por supuesto
tememos por nuestra democracia pero
también somos resistentes
para estos activistas no hay duda de que
joe biden debería ganar las elecciones
pero los partidarios republicanos
también se están manifestando en varios
estados en defensa les donald trump yo
ni nadie ni un solo republicano ha sido
capaz de mirar ninguna de estas boletas
de correo podrían ser de marzo podrían
ser del comité nacional democrático joe
biden podría haber votado 50 veces o
5000 veces hasta donde sabemos
en washington la capital federal algunas
voces demócratas piden un cambio en el
sistema para poner fin a estas
incertidumbres
ha llegado el momento de cuestionar
todas nuestras instituciones incluyendo
el colegio electoral estas son cosas que
deberíamos cuestionar no necesariamente
tienen sentido no es que lo tuvieran
cuando se promulgaron por primera vez
fueron promulgados en un mundo muy
diferente y por personas que también
tenían mucho poder concentrado al
transferir agua
cada uno con sus propios argumentos cree
que quiere proteger la democracia
americana una democracia que ha sido
duramente golpeada en las últimas horas
[Música]
arizona también fue foco de las
protestas donde según la agencia para el
voto ya está decidido a favor de joe
biden allí los simpatizantes de
donaldson protestaron a las afueras de
la oficina electoral del condado de
maricopa para denunciar fraude en las
elecciones inspirados en lo dicho por
donald trump sin tener ningún tipo de
pruebas y han obligado a los encargados
del regreso a detener el escrutinio por
su parte la policía vigilaba tanto el
exterior del edificio como el proceso de
conteo que se desarrollaba en el
interior
para analizar lo que ocurre en eeuu dos
días después de estas elecciones
presidenciales quiero saludar en este
momento a josé antonio egido analista
internacional doctor en sociología por
la universidad de provenza en marsella
gracias por estar con nosotros profesor
hasta dónde podría llegar la batalla
legal del presidente donald trump luego
de impugnar estas elecciones en varios
estados
bueno gracias por la invitación todo
todo aparenta que el equipo republicano
del párking en torno a trump ha
preparado equipos legales para hacer
durar mucho una batalla legal no después
de que ha fallado la autoproclamación
como presidente dándose en la primera
noche el como vencedor es importante lo
que pasa en nevada pero es importante
también el clima de inestabilidad que se
está generando en todo el país
ahora bien trump ha convertido a eeuu en
el epicentro de la pandemia ha
demostrado ser lo suficientemente
irresponsable como para arrastrar a su
país a la inestabilidad fruto de un
largo proceso legal habida cuenta de que
él ha nombrado a varios magistrados del
alto tribunal de los eeuu una situación
bien compleja no tenga la menor duda así
de jose antonio ahora el presidente
donald trump ha dicho en varias
oportunidades y lo sigue diciendo que
hubo fraude electoral le preguntó bajo
qué pruebas porque hasta ahora nadie
claro yo no he respondido yo eso sí no
los actores políticos norteamericanos
que dicen cómo es posible que hable de
fraude sin presentar una sola prueba lo
que estamos viendo aquí es una
repetición del síndrome why do que trump
el intento en venezuela ahora él está
intentando hacer lo mismo al menos en
este caso sí es verdad que se ha
presentado a unas elecciones
presidenciales lo que no en el caso
tengo ha ido pero ambos resultados ambas
ambos no ven métodos no van a dar un
buen resultado porque en votos numéricos
biden habla de 70 millones eso está
bastante computado aunque hay que
reconocer que trump tiene 68 millones de
votos aunque ya sabemos que lo que
cuenta son los colegios electorales algo
que no entiende nadie en el mundo porque
solamente funcionan los estados unidos
de norteamérica y es quien puede ganar
las elecciones aún perdiendo el número
de votos directos de cada ciudadano en
francia no pasa si en américa latina
tampoco así es josé antonio pero
entonces en ese contexto
a pedir que se pare este conteo de los
votos no estaría desconociendo los casi
100 millones de votos que han llegado
por correo el voto anticipado ese es
otro asunto el número de votos por
correo que son masivos yo creo que hay
que reconocer que trump ha cometido un
gran número de votos ha tumbado las
encuestas que es un método inventado en
los propios eeuu las encuestas no han
funcionado porque daban diez o veinte
puntos por encima y piden pero queda
efectivamente el número de el número de
papeletas por correo ahora hay un
problema añadido
eeuu no cuenta con una autoridad
electoral fiable que pueda digamos
interponerse entre los intereses de las
dos partes en conflicto de manera que
al parecer va a ser la calle la presión
de la calle la que va a determinar un
poco la capacidad que tiene trump de
resistir a lo que parece ser una
inevitable derrota parece ser así esos
de antonio gracias por estar con
nosotros gracias por su tiempo feliz el
resto de día allá en españa vamos hasta
washington dice con nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal buen día el
candidato demócrata se acerca a la cifra
necesaria delegados electorales para ser
electo presidente de eeuu cuales son las
matemáticas que tendría que hacer él y
trump para revertir esta situación
raúl bailén tiene en este momento 264
votos electorales necesita seis más los
seis que le puede otorgar nevada en
estado precisamente en la costa oeste
que está en disputa y que hoy
precisamente pues entregará resultados
sobre su voto por correo lo que dicen
muchos analistas y pronostican es que
esos seis votos electorales pues le
sumarán para que va a llegar a los 270
votos electorales así que bien sólo
necesitaría ganar un estado más esto sin
contar pues la tendencia a ganar que
dice el partido demócrata que puede
lograr bailén en pensilvania incluso en
georgia en el caso del presidente de
trump tiene que ganar todos los estados
que están en juego es decir georgia
alaska nevada carolina del norte y
pennsylvania para poder llegar a estas
cifras mágicas de los 270 votos
electorales cristóbal por supuesto le
vamos a preguntar las reacciones
políticas que hay ante esta situación
que vive eeuu
claro recordemos que de parte de los
republicanos de la campaña de donald
trump insiste en que es el jefe de
campaña de trump pues ha dicho que pues
se llamaba a denunciar
en michigan para que el conteo de votos
haya pares lo que argumentan es que
ellos no tuvieron acceso a los reportes
de votos y que entonces pues tienen que
denunciar para que haya supuestamente
seguridad más claridad más transparencia
en el conteo de los votos en wisconsin
están pidiendo un reconteo de votos y
pues en las horas de la tarde ayer el
hijo de donald trump eric trump en
filadelfia estuvo dando un discurso
diciendo que lo que está pasando en este
momento en eeuu es que a su padre le
están arrebatando las elecciones por
otro lado bailén pues se mostró muy
optimista en este discurso pequeño de 10
minutos que dio ayer diciendo que pues
va camino a la victoria pero que hay que
contar cada voto y que él gobernará para
todos los americanos independientemente
de que hayan votado por él o no
cristóbal gracias por la información que
tengo ustedes muy buen día continuamos
con el avance de eta convertida ahora en
tormenta tropical el antes huracán tocó
tierra en honduras luego de su paso por
nicaragua donde dejó al menos cuatro
personas fallecidas y graves
inundaciones las autoridades hondureñas
aunque las lluvias serán catastróficas y
recomendar el nuevo acuario a unas
30.000 personas hacia sitios seguros en
panamá el fenómeno natural deja al menos
8 personas desaparecidas entre ellas dos
niños por centroamérica es todo un
conjunto sistémico cuando ésta cruza la
frontera sigue echando agua en las
montañas y una parte de esa agua bien a
nuestro frío por tanto tenemos que estar
muy atentos
entonces sumemos todos esos factores
lluvia e intensidad importante 2
saturación del suelo
entonces y zona montañosa como decimos
cuando los suelos están saturados todo
lo que cae corre cargamos ahora
información porque europa continúa
haciendo frente a la segunda ola de
contagios de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
mayoría de los países del bloque
comunitario imponen nuevas restricciones
más estrictas para evitar el avance del
virus en un nido entró hoy en un nuevo
confinamiento general mientras el primer
ministro boris johnson prepara una
campaña de pruebas a gran escala cuando
finalice este nuevo confinamiento del
próximo 2 de diciembre ayer miércoles el
país registró un récord
492 muertes diarias cifra que no se daba
desde mayo
hasta que el informativo que tiene con
nosotros
[Música]